[Music]
is your husband a jockey as well
no he's six foot six oh my god yeah he's
a big dude if you see yeah
one like six four and a half six eight
if the hair is up six eleven I'm well
over seven feet tall
yeah but you you okay this is
fascinating he so he couldn't be a
jockey he's way too big to be into yeah
I mean he's not exactly says a horse but
he's you know he's a big dude and he
[Applause]
I don't know what their problem is
just ignore them they're insane what
does he do is he an athlete as well um
he's played football but not
professionally
he owns a manufacturing company so he
sells bacon and he is allergic to horses
actually he's allergic to horses yeah
and he married a jockey yeah so when I
come home I have to basically you know
take off my work clothes and then in the
garage and then I go in the house wait
you go home yeah you go into the garage
and strip naked and then walk into the
house yeah because you just can't have
the dander in the house are you sure
maybe he's just lying and wants to
[Applause]
that's fantastic now I'm suddenly
allergic to all kinds of stuff wow
that's incredible
alright now I don't know much about
actually I really don't know much about
horse racing I'll be honest with you but
I know that is there is there if I were
to meet a male jockey he'd be quite
small as men go is that not the case
with women
well most jockeys are about five four
five by five I'm five foot two I
probably look more proportionate because
I'm a girl and small but right a man is
my size that they seem to look smaller
right right what's the what is the when
you're on a horse and you're going top
speed on a horse just how fast you what
are you talking about you're 40 miles
per hour is it really 40 miles an mm Wow
okay
yeah crashing is not fun you know just
don't do it that stop crashing have you
fallen off the horse going 40 miles an
hour that yeah I have it's not a
strategy for that and you just still
like here we go and I either will wake
up from this or I won't I mean I
honestly don't know is there if you
start to go up a horse at 40 miles an
hour what are you supposed to do well
you know I was on a horse once and just
launched me in the air and you're
airborne going it's gonna hurt uh-huh
and you just try to think roll or brace
yourself
but yeah it's I'm lucky enough I'd
bounce pretty good you bounce people are
watching you she goes but you're fine
you know major injuries and a few
stitches here and there
okay how about does anything you
obviously you've got to have quite a
nerve quite you know steady nerves too
and and be a bit of a thrill seeker to
be able to ride a horse professionally
forty miles an hour
what do you like when you're just
driving to you know to the to buy some
popcorn at the popcorn shop the hell am
I talking about
I'll stick with this listen there's a
popcorn shop a shop that just sells
popcorn you want to get there but it's
too far to walk and taking the horse
would be dumb all right what do you like
as a driver um my girlfriend Anna would
say that she thinks I'm insane and she
gets nervous when I'm she's in the car
with me I think I are you riding it like
a horse you behind it real no I'd like
to drive fast and I like fast things
anything fast best cars best boats fast
horses I like it you've convinced me if
I I love that story about your husband
not just fantastic it's really got me
scheming I don't know what to tell MA
I'm allergic to baby seats in the
backseat
take off your clothes
have you ever come home and like the
Cable guy's there yeah you walk in naked
well I'm finally naked and there's a guy
there installing HBO not yet hasn't
happened yet
all right let's know something to look
forward to
note to self rent cable uniform
[Applause]